[Music]
so consciousness is one of the deepest
mysteries that we have ever attempted to
resolve and part of the problem with
studying consciousness is that it's very
difficult to measure but there's we do
have some insights and for one in the
context of how the brain tells time
there's evidence that consciousness is
not really what it seems to be so what I
mean by that is we feel the cantar
subjective experiences unfolding in the
world around us in sort of this linear
narrative in which B follows a in which
he follows B and D follows C in which
things are happening in a linear
progression but in reality it seems that
our subjective experiences our conscious
narrative might not be that linear so
there's a number of experiences or
experiments that suggest that the brain
processes information in sort of a
discontinuous and discreet manner so
it's not that I'm conscious of
everything happening in a nice linear
progression it seems to be in some cases
that what happens after interferes or
modulates what our conscious experience
of those things that came before so
there's something called the cutaneous
rabbit illusion in which if you feel a
couple of taps on your arm maybe one two
three four people will feel that as sort
of a continuous progression but in
reality that can't be a continuous
progression because it's the taps that
came later that determined where you
felt that the previous taps were
occurring and if you think of something
like speech you're probably not aware of
my speech and a syllable by syllable
word by word manner you seems to be that
that we become conscious of
events all around us sort of in chunks
in which your unconscious mind reaches a
point of analysis by taking in sampling
everything that's happening around it
before a subjective experience is
delivered into your conscious mind so I
think there's some suggestions that the
unconscious brain is continuously taking
in sampling events from through its
sensory organs waiting to appropriate
points in the narrative to deliver
something a nice narrative of the world
around us into our conscious mind so in
the case of speech for example we don't
have an experience of a brief every
syllable syllable by syllable every word
by word but sometimes we have this
chunking that happens so for example if
I say the mousepad was beside the
computer in that case the mouse could
have another meaning the mouse could
mean a rodent or it could be the
mousepad of a computer but you only knew
the meaning of the word Mouse with the
word in this case that came after the
word Mouse so the mousepad I could have
said the mouse was hungry so the meaning
of the word Mouse can only be understood
based on what comes after that so it
seems that when people understand that
they are seeing might have to wait to
the appropriate time to create a
conscious perception or a conscious
interpretation of what we're listening
to so I think there's mounting evidence
that consciousness is not a linear flow
of what's happening around us but sort
of a creation a narrative convenient
narrative of what's happening around us
created for our viewing pleasure by the
unconscious brain
[Music]